um
[Music]
perfect
love it
ah
greetings all
oh
I was trying to figure out why is the
white so
bright on my face and then I was trying
to compensate for and I realized oh
right it's because I had
done a restart
on my
um
there we go I've done a restart on my
computer uh to do updates and my presets
for my ring light switch back to the
default which is the brightest setting
so that that's better that is better
that's
yeah that'll do my forehead's a little
shinier than I'd like but what whatever
I'll deal with it I'll deal with it
your birthday in about eight hours Leon
well
I hope you have a good one when you get
there
hey everybody it's great to see you all
Tracy thank you very much for the Super
Chat happy birthday
um reminder that the uh if you are not a
patreon member and thus uh have access
to the uh Council of Geeks Discord the
way to guarantee that I see your comment
or question is to do it as a super chat
thank you LT LT Smash Thank you so much
happy birthday I appreciate that
immensely and you also get a heart from
me uh for the super chats I will of
course try and keep up
um with the
chat as it goes but you know
super task get highlighted it's it it's
a simple guarantee to be sure that I'll
see it uh
I hope folks are doing well hey there
Ben a forehead Shine the bane of my
videos it can be hard to compensate for
see the thing is like I've got a pretty
good setup for my normal video shooting
but it's it's streaming that it doesn't
uh doesn't pan out quite as consistently
as I'd like
I was just getting caught up on your B5
podcast yeah which went out a day late
and I initially uploaded the wrong
episode so that
uh it's been a very nice day but that
was the one major thing to be like okay
let's throw a wrench into things a
little bit
I'm in the third season of Steven
Universe really enjoying it oh good
that's a good show my kiddo loves that
show
I don't even know how many times she's
rewatched it start to finish it's been a
lot
it's been a lot
I watched your video yesterday oh I
assume you mean the one that went up on
the Vera wild Channel
um in case folks don't know or didn't
see
um I posted about it in the community
tab but I put a Vero uh viral video up
on the Vero wild Channel which is a
separate channel from this one because
it talks more explicitly about my own
experiences as a gender fluid person
sometimes it's product reviews and and
stuff like that
um that isn't necessarily geeky so
that's why the content isn't here and
yeah I did I did a video covering what I
consider to be my 30-year transition
timeline since I basically started
first experimenting with gender at about
11. and as of today
I am 41.
three decades of gender nonsense
that could be a title for an
autobiography
um
happy birthday wishes from Germany thank
you Michael I appreciate that
not a single gray hair on you that's not
true at all Miss Wicked Wolf like the
lighting in here
is pretty forgiving I have a lot of gray
hairs
I'm embarrassed by them I'm not ashamed
of them but I
if you're not seeing them you're not
like I believe that you don't see them
that well in this setup but like if
you're not seeing them then you're not
paying attention because they're
definitely there
ah
um so Tara if you look for so there's a
uh I have uh Tara is looking for the
video where I initially did my coming
out uh here on this channel so if you go
to
I have a playlist for Q a videos
it is the second video in there
and it's towards the tail end it might
be a
round I don't remember how long the
video in the video is it's like in the
last the last quarter or so of the video
is mostly about that
that's assuming that
someone else hasn't already directed you
there getting drunk no getting buzzed
uh
there's a joke in one of the culture
novels that has the word gay in it do
you think you'd even have words for gay
or straight if your Society has no
sexuality prejudices well
I suppose it depends on the exact
context because there is there is the
um basic Bare Bones facts of sexuality
that is gay or straight and then there
is sort of
gay or straight
mentality arguably gay culture like
things like that might still persist in
a way that makes use of the word maybe
not like I would imagine it wouldn't
have a ton of meanings in its strictest
definition but that doesn't mean it
couldn't have some meaning
um I'd have to see the full context on
that doomsday thoughts uh I don't really
have any I mean the whole thing just
gives me real big time lord Victorious
Vibes and ultimately I didn't I didn't
pay attention to that too and
I have been paranoid back when that
happened to be like I don't know if I
like if I have the spoons or the time or
the money to follow all this am I going
to be left behind and then the general
consensus was okay well that happened
so like it's a neat idea I don't think
it's a bad idea it's cool fine enjoy I'm
not
not planning to out of my way to take it
all in
I'm still young I like to think so
certainly young in Behavior if nothing
else
ah Thomas Jerome Newton happy
regeneration anniversary thank you
thank you very much
uh
everybody watch that video the picture
of Veron High School is adorable like I
find it it just see
here's the thing about the the picture
that I ended up using in that
normally when I make references to
myself in high school I am partial to
making use of my senior photo
which
is is its own kind of like really but
um that one I think was my junior year
that picture the reason I use that one
is because I was making reference in the
video to the dress code and your senior
picture did not have to be in dress code
so me using that one didn't make a lot
of sense so I kind of had to use the one
I did and and yeah it is I think
adorkable uh would be a fitting enough
term
my top 41 pieces of media why are they
your favorite that is not a question
that we have time for
uh that is an entertaining one to ponder
though uh Alyssa
our philosophy is thank you very much
for the Super Chat I appreciate that
greatly if your birthday gift was one
change to pop culture entertainment what
would it be
ah
my brain's going a few different places
at once
on that
um
honestly
um personally
selfishly the removal of humiliation
humor
I it just hurts
and sometimes it shows up in stuff that
like I'm not expecting it and it hurts
it hurts a lot I hate it
you thought I was 25 it liar
this Channel's been around for over a
decade you thought I started when I was
15. no
sorry to hear about Bo but yeah
you know he had a he had a real good run
you've been with me for so much of my
transition when I was denying
questioning again and now out and
transitioning for one and a half years
even planning surgery now oh
that's great Louise I'm really happy for
you and like I hope you don't ever feel
um
shame in
you know denying and questioning and
that and that process because it it's a
process we all have to go through and I
know it's it can be a very common thing
to sort of
mourn the time where you didn't
um
you didn't live as Who You Now
understand yourself to be but I hope
that
um you can treasure now knowing and
better understanding and appreciate the
journey that you took
and I don't want to negate the the other
perspective but I find it more valid
when one is in a position where one
knows but can't do anything whether it
be for safety reasons financial reasons
living condition reasons you know
whatever
um whereas like if it just took you that
long to figure yourself out like
maybe that's the time you need it
possibly
it's how I tend to think of myself at
any rate
John vinyls
thank you very much so the trailer for
watching and dreaming came out also
thoughts on moon girl and devil dinosaur
I am not aware of watching and dreaming
so I know neither what that is nor have
I seen the trailer I have not watched
any of moon growing devil dinosaur I saw
some of the early preview stuff it
looked fine it looked like the kind of
thing that
just felt like it was best for me to
skip simply because I mean weird
comparison but to compare it to
something like the Sarah Jane Adventures
it looks good for the for the Target
demographic for the age group and the
audience it's aimed at
looks real good I do not occupy that
targeted demographic that doesn't mean
that I automatically won't like it but
it does make me generally cautious
because I don't like to feel like I'm
nitpicking something that isn't for me
if that makes sense
like sometimes I I feel more justified
in doing that but in general I try to
avoid it
do I consider myself an Aries uh I do
barely
barely but yes I do
uh let's see where was I
look real good for your age thank you I
appreciate that
Lessons Learned thank you very much for
the Super Chat I appreciate that very
much
I was gonna ask if you like being called
adorkable I don't know if I'd appreciate
it being called that now because I don't
it's certainly not what I aim for
looking at me in high school I think it
fits
I think that works
trying to come up with descriptions of
every doctor whose story using Tim Curry
quotes
that's a fun project
oh I love that already
uh best one so far as Castro Valley
who'll probably be in
in the Zen room
[Laughter]
oh Rowan that is a
that is a wonderful wonderful project I
love it I love it
I'm currently reading who hunts the
whale by Laura K Dale and Jane aerith
magnet yeah I I
if it hits audiobook I might get to it
it's physical books are harder for me to
get through these days
um
but I'm really I'm really glad they got
it out I know I know the two of them
have been working on that for a long
time
I'll be 40 later this year I like to
think that aging is a privilege so many
people never get to this age
that that is a valid way of looking at
it
Leon styles thank you very much for the
super sticker good job
thanks so much
uh if your one birthday gift was owning
the Doctor Who I pee what would you do
with it also happy birthday
um
for the sake of my own
creative stress probably get somebody
else to to manage a whole bunch of it
um
the thing I don't really know like
sometimes people will ask me like if you
could write a doctor whose story what
would it be like I have a couple of
broad ideas that maybe I could do
something with but like
ah
it's easier and this is an
acknowledgment of like some of the
failings or not failings but limitations
of
geeky punditry the other very nature of
what I do but it's easier to fine-tune a
thing that that exists and is already
happening go okay that could have been
better if x was y or if you swapped that
with this or maybe if you just didn't do
that or had you considered this it's a
lot easier to offer input and feedback
and direction on a thing that is done
trying to figure out where to steer a
thing
where the form that it takes is
completely on your back that's a lot
harder and it's not only that but it's
difficult for me
to get my creative brain to
work with me
if I don't think that
this story actually goes anywhere and in
the case of something like Doctor Who
this I mean this is part of why I've
never written fan fiction I don't think
I ever could it's just that
in my mind like this is never going to
be a story that happens in this thing so
my brain just kind of checks out and go
I'm not I'm not wasting energy on that
what are you doing it's it's also why
I'm generally bad at speculation and I'm
a bad person to ask for fan theories
because
my brain won't let me just I
I can't just allocate brain power to
whatever I want it my brain will fight
me on it and it will fight me big time
if it's something that requires Creative
Energy
but won't result in something
so like fan theories it's like my I can
try and think of fan theories and my
brain just goes
what are you doing what use use this
energy for something else just watch it
when it comes out and see what it is why
are you theorizing and it's kind of the
same thing with you know thoughts of
like what would you do with the ISP
where would you take the story and I'm
just
they're not bad questions I'm just a bad
person to ask
it's just how that kind of pans out
well there you go Tara I hope you see
Carolyn gave you the uh the link oh and
a timestamp thank you for doing that
Carolyn I appreciate that immensely it's
very kind of you
uh Supremo Mega thank you very much for
the Super Chat
do you feel another issue you have with
Damien this being Damien Wayne Uh is
he's a male version of Cass and Damian
was heavily promoted while cast was
sideline and raised in the new 52.
um
I don't think that's part of my personal
baggage
although now that you've said that
that's a valid point
because
in terms of having a member of the bat
family who was trained to be an assassin
and needs to be sure not to make use of
a bunch of skills that they have because
they'll kill somebody
yeah you're right they did already do
that
oh actually that hadn't even occurred to
me so
it certainly wasn't one of my issues
prior to you bringing it up
that is kind of an issue though
I'm sorry Cass is just way more
interesting Damien's
he's not interesting
he's just not
hmm
given that virus 41 doesn't mean we can
call her a boomer no Boomer isn't about
a number for your age Boomer is a
generation Boomer is being of the baby
boom generation I'm a millennial
I'm an elder Millennial but I'm a
millennial so no I'm not a boomer
I'm not a boomer Gen X folks can't be
Boomers my mother's a boomer
ah let's see where
was I here we go
didn't realize I was gender fluid until
my mid late 50s so it's not too late
damn right
damn right Carolyn
whenever you realize it
it's not too late make the use of the
now and the time that you have
if you know who you are
be it
if it took you longer to realize who you
were then would have been ideal I get
the frustration but don't let that stop
you from being
Thomas Pape dang Thomas Pape my goodness
very generous and thank you
thank you very much I appreciate that
immensely also first Super Chat from you
the chat is telling me the system is so
thank you extra
for that
Dharma thank you very much for the super
chat now is always the best time to be
yourself yes
yes it is and there is no shame in
needing time to figure out who that is
ah
cool Millennial that might be a stretch
um
they shouldn't say you look good for
your age you simply look good oh
thank you Thomas
Aries is a fire witch Aries is a lot of
things but again like it's messy for me
because I'm I'm
right on the cusp I'm very cuspy
much less reflective but have you ever
seen the Hunger Games movies me and a
lot of the internet have been into them
again lately
I've seen the first one and the second
one I didn't see the last two
um
there was a lot I could appreciate about
the first one
um
ultimately though it didn't leave that
much of an impression and the second the
second one is odd to me because the
second one is in many ways a better
movie than the first one but it's
repeating so many of the same Beats
that it loses my interest despite being
better
which is you know it just didn't leave
me in a place where I'm like I'm Keen
for more
and I know feelings seem to be very
mixed on the well on the third book in
the last two movies in general opinion
is the third movie is very bloated and
padded out and probably didn't need to
be there and
I don't know I never came back after
that
Aaron oh happy b b day fellow I'm gonna
say fellow Aries just because me saying
that word I understand what you mean by
me saying that word out loud sounds like
something else and I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna say that and have people
clip it
but thank you Aaron thank you very very
much
um
it tends to throw people who are into
astrology off when I tell them that I'm
an Aries but then I'm explaining that
like I'm right on the cusp and they're
like oh okay that makes a lot more sense
watching and dreaming is the new Owl
House episode oh comes out on April 8th
oh didn't realize it was getting a
trailer I will probably skip that I
would rather go in cold on that I think
am I including TV shows in my MCU
ranking including the Netflix shows too
yeah all of that is built into the tier
uh ranking template that I'm using
they're all going to show up and
actually I can tell you right now the
Netflix shows especially
are going to be difficult
because
the ones that I like I don't like all
the seasons so
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna name which
ones I'm thinking of but like they're
they're certainly some of our first
season amazing second season what are we
doing and that happened more than once
so uh yeah though the shows are gonna be
tricky and I'm also going to have to
guesstimate with some of them because
some of them I didn't finish but we will
uh
we will deal with that when we get to
Saturday
I can be naughty in my 40s Adrian you
said as if I haven't been naughty long
before now
I consider myself more of a bleeding
edge X than trailing Boomer I think that
fits you fits you better Caroline not
value really strikes Boomer to me
bleeding edge X I like that I like I
like that for you a lot
ah let's see
John vinyls who's cuter loose and Amity
or kit and Jade
kit and Jade
I'm drawing a blank on
who that is
um
oh wait a second wait a second
oh from Willow
[Music]
hell I didn't go back to Willow after
the first
three episodes I didn't go back to it it
just didn't hold my attention
and it'll be hard to motivate myself now
that it's been canceled so
came for the birthday chat stay for the
lace work on the neck curtains
I will not be doing an interior design
video like the bits of the top of this
dresser that you can see in the mess
there that is much more indicative of my
design philosophy than the um
then the curtains are
Reina thank you very much slice of
birthday cake much appreciated thank you
so much
uh Russell T Davis said new Doctor Who
is one of the greatest things he's ever
made I'm glad he's being enthusiastic we
shall all be the judge of that
just taking a villain moment
okay couple more for survival
we are all
animals
for blood so strange as him saying Rocky
oh goodness leaning heavily on uh
Rocky Horror I'm noticing Fair it's very
quotable
what's Gen X I forget the exact age
range Gen X was the Generation
Um prior to millennial
I forget the exact
range that it's supposed to fall under
but again like when you get right to the
right to the turnover moments it gets
weird and squidgy
um because like you'll find definitions
for Generations that will give you a
hard
um gear like where this one ends and
this one starts but like in terms of
what your life experience is actually
like if you're at the very end of one
generation there's a good chance you're
going to relate much more to the people
who are technically at the start of the
next one
um or possibly vice versa depending on
you know your lovering situation how
things grew up it's it's one of the
things that so like a good example of
that
I think um
there excuse me
there's a decent number of
um Millennials with Gen X sensibilities
to some degree and I find more often
than not it's usually because they had
older siblings
like a whole bunch of people my age are
like
they're way more into the 80s than they
should be given that like they're into
stuff that at the time they were like
two or three but they had older siblings
who were really into that so they kind
of absorbed it through them or maybe
even into some stuff from the 70s
depending on age range so yeah it can
get weird and squidgy at the edges
a person I like Damien's Dynamic with
young John Kent was in Super Sons I did
hear really good things about super Sons
I will grant that I won't I won't pass
judgment on that book because from
people whose opinions I respect said it
was really good I never read it
um
still don't like Damien in a Batman
setting though
I'm in my 60s I'm a boomer you've taught
me so much on here oh thank you Thomas
foreign
let's see
colzo Art thank you for the Super Chat
thank you for all the work you put in
here happy birthday thank you
I appreciate that
Our Lady of the cusp
that works
that works indeed
uh you need your chart done to be really
sure need daytime place of birth can do
it for free nowadays with all the
software I'm aware
amore
I didn't even realize Owl House was
still making episodes I thought it was
canceled years ago it was canceled about
a year and a half two years back in
terms of having another full proper
season they they gave them three
45-minute specials to wrap up the story
two of them have already aired the third
one happens next month
Daredevil will come back without foggy
Nelson yeah yeah that is a bummer I
agree Gozer that is
a shame
finally made it to Ms Marvel on my
Marvel catch up three episodes in I
think it's fun and Mom uh Iman villani
is definitely my favorite part so far
and like I
I enjoyed Ms Marvel
I don't think the narrative they chose
to do especially by the time it was done
worked for six episodes
I feel like they they crammed a second
season's worth of plot into the middle
of it and it
um
like the cast was good A lot of the
overall instincts of the storytelling
was good but the structure of the thing
overall didn't
it I feel I feel like it really suffered
from only being six episodes
I feel like it either should have been
longer or one of the storylines should
have been pushed to a second season
is sort of My overall opinion on that
what piece of media is your super
villain origin story my money's still on
the Dexter finale
that
um
there's a compelling argument to be made
I would say that is probably it I think
the Dexter
uh series finale this is original Dexter
Run I think that series finale
was probably my first taste of being
truly
anger-inducingly
just deeply infuriated
with a piece of Television media
specifically certainly something that
I'd been invested in had been following
for years really enjoying and then that
last season was kind of and then we get
to the final episode it's like what
what yeah oh I think yeah you might you
might have gotten it in one there Ben
I love foggy and the other one was a
page Karen Page is who you're thinking
of there Robin
uh
mine's on Ghostbusters too see the thing
about Ghostbusters 2 is I was a little
bit too young for it to really hit me
with anger
when I first saw Ghostbusters 2 I didn't
like it and I wasn't entirely sure why
but I largely moved on and just kept
rewatching the first one and watching
the cartoon and I was fine it it was
only really upon revisiting it
as an adult and being able to better
articulate why I didn't like it that I
found sort of new levels of with it but
like that had to be rediscovered Dexter
finale
oh when that hit ah dang it
that that was uh that was that wasn't
pleasant
ah
wait will it was canceled yes it was
um or at okay so it's it's weird it's
weird so
the official word I think from Disney
itself was that it was canceled the
Creator is saying technically it's not
canceled in that they're not saying
they'll never do more but what they are
doing is they are releasing the cast
because if they get the chance to do
more it's not going to happen right away
which means there they need to you know
they're not going to pay to retain the
cast they're gonna let them go so they
can go get other work
which makes it effectively canceled the
the Creator behind the show has been
very quick to be like it still could get
more but right now it's effectively
canceled
any thoughts on Twilight I found the
last movie to be the most interesting
about saying something so first thing on
Twilight I never read the books I only
saw the movies
and yes the last one is by far the most
interesting because it's bonkers
it is Bonkers it's made by people who
are very clearly gone this is the last
time we have to do this let's go nuts
and
I don't think it's good
but it's also kind of amazing it's it's
weird like it doesn't work as a
standalone here's the thing to
appreciate how off the rails that last
movie is you can't appreciate that
unless you've watched the four movies
prior but I don't think it's worth
sitting through the four movies prior in
order to get to that so yeah
it's mud season it is the snow is
continuing tomorrow it was almost 60
here today actually
uh
Supremo Mega thank you very much on red
hood do you feel a reason why he doesn't
work as a character in main Canon is
that hundreds in the 90s did his thing
way better no the main reason I think he
doesn't work as a character in Canon is
that his impact on Batman is more
meaningful if he's dead
if he is the robin who died if he is the
the kid who died
because Batman brought him into this
world thinking he was going to make his
life better and then that
he died
that as a meaningful reverberance across
everything he does if he's not dead
that's kind of gone now I have said
elsewhere that I'll caveat that in that
the brief period where red hood kind of
worked was when he was a villain
when he so that he could still stand as
Batman's greatest failure
where okay he's not dead anymore but he
is very much nothing that Batman would
ever want want him to be and arguably
when he was just killing people possibly
more effective at stopping crime that
Batman was
um or at the very least challenging
Batman's approach that could have worked
but they dropped that made him an
anti-hero and then he's basically just a
straight up good guy at this point he
just happens to use guns which is deeply
uninteresting and robs us of the weight
of him being Batman's greatest failure
which is where I think the character is
interesting Huntress having done the
vigilante willing to kill things before
him I mean
it wasn't even that unique to Huntress
it was I I guess it was a little unique
within the Batman within the bat family
specifically but like in comics it
wasn't even that original when she did
it so I'm not even gonna knock that uh
particularly
what let's see
I've heard the Dungeons and Dragons is a
fun movie
um I might uh I might see if my kiddo
wants to go see that because she's into
d d now
um so she might go for that
excuse me it's out this weekend right
I might see if if she'll be up for that
am I entering my villain era now see the
thing is I
if I was
I'm not sure I'd know
because there are the villains
who know they're the villains
and then there are the villains who
genuinely don't think that they are
who feel that they're doing what is
necessary
doing what is right doing what other
people won't do because
they're not as strong as you are
does that make you a villain
to them maybe but would you call that
your villain era
because you'll take the steps they won't
make the stands that they won't make
do what has to be done
when they are too cowardly to do it
or you know you could just do the evil
villain cackling thing whatever works
ah
Lynn Wallace thank you very much for the
Super Chat happy birthday from Maine a
Maine's lovely uh I like that you put a
mons a lobster
Maine Lobster mobster yeah I like that
you put a lobster in there because when
people tell me they're from Maine my
general follow-up question is lobster
main or moose Mane
Lobster very nice
ah
do what do I think of the court of owls
Batman Saga I don't like it at all I do
not like the court of owls I don't like
its existence
I don't like
I don't like how it was executed it was
good for about
four issues of the comic and then it
went to hell real quick hey Meg good to
see you I'm glad you made it
cheers
um
Suggs Suggs with a box suggest with a
box I don't
Suggs with the box thank you thank you
for the Super Chat it's very generous I
appreciate that
uh
ah see where was I
this is Marvel shoved 12 issues of comic
since it's six episodes even still I
really enjoyed it like again I don't
think it's bad I just really want to
restructure it
Timothy Dalton turned 77 today
you wanna talk about
looking awesome for his age damn
huh
I haven't watched Dexter what's so bad
about it the okay short version
the finale feels like it's not even it's
not even strictly a narrative thing
although there are some narrative
choices that it's like what but it's not
it's not a game of thrones thing where
the narrative just doesn't fit where it
was going the final episode of Dexter
feels like it was made by people who
never watched a single episode of Dexter
it nothing about the tone the mood the
aesthetic the feel the atmosphere but
nothing feels like Dexter Dexter was a
show that ran on tension and there's
this weird dreamlike quality to the
finale that it just feels like it's not
even from the same damn show on top of
having some badly executed stupid ideas
do you ever find yourself feeling
nostalgic for periods you didn't
actually live through like stranger
thing gives me a nostalgic Buzz even
though I was born in 1993. um
yeah sometimes
I can take in certain 60s or 70s or
honestly even like Roaring 20s style
media
um and be like yeah yeah that could have
been fun
John vinyls
thank you very much
do you think there's an all-powerful
conspiracy to sink queers genre shows
like Owl House or dead end or Willow or
is there a non-homophobic explanation
well okay so slightly two different
questions there do I think there's a
conspiracy no do I think there's a
non-homophobic explanation no the thing
is homophobia does not require intent
there is such a thing as passive
homophobia uh or queer phobia or what
have you where you aren't actively
trying to remove it or dismantle it but
you are not you are looking at it in a
way that does not take into
consideration its value in media it's
valuing culture it's value to people who
are not represented you just
you even people who try and treat all
will treat everything the same anything
that is under the structures that are
currently governing entertainment
anything that is underrepresented will
just continue to be underrepresented in
that way so there's a lot of passive
homophobia in that nobody is taking into
consideration what does it look like
that we keep canceling all these queer
shows they're just in their mind
canceling a show like here's the ratings
here's what we sunk into it oh we should
cancel that and
there is there is a lack of
consideration is the difference between
malice and ignorance I think there's a
lot of ignorant homophobia in
queerphobia and transphobia behind a lot
of those kinds of
um cancellations of queer genre shows I
don't think there's a ton of deliberate
malicious intent
I'm not going to say it's impossible
that there's some but I don't think so I
gener I generally find it is more
helpful to uh if something feels like it
might be conspiracy there's a good
chance it's much more likely idiocy or
incompetence
don't the thing to remember about
conspiracy if you come up with a
conspiracy theory
you are crediting them with being able
to make plans and being smart I don't
think these people are smart I think
they're idiots so I talk a lot more
things up to idiocy and incompetence
let's see
currently in the middle of watching
episode 36 of corn swords I just have
episodes 37 and 38 I should have watched
them by the time you all do episode 39
so I'll be watching on Twitch oh that's
great neck and crochet tiger I hope to
see you there
ah
just finished watching the servant
anyone else check that out on Apple TV
plus Apple TV is one of the few I don't
have so that's a negative on me Meg
thank you uh denox for the birthday
wishes I appreciate that even though we
disagree on some ideas hey you nobody is
required to uh agree with me
sorry about the half-hearted heart thing
it was it was just a highlighted comment
not a super chat you kind of you kind of
got a half heart out of me because I was
running on autopilot there for a hot
second
um
happy birthday
uh we'll uh like watching will open an
Atari on Christmas weirdly gave me a
nostalgic Buzz even though I had a
GameCube when I was his age I mean I
think being able to relate to that
sensation even though it's a different
system like that makes it pretty
relatable
um do I have a favorite short story
writer ooh I'm gonna try I'd ever
thought about that
probably
but I I don't know off the top of my
head I'd have to think about that
ah
finally finished streaming Heathcliff
and the Cadillac cats interesting choice
I wish Dexter was still around to cross
over with the Ripoff series you I've not
seen you I've heard
all right I'm not gonna say I've heard
good things I've heard fun trash which
fun trash is fair
I have I have caught up to the chat
reacting to when I started feeling
monologuing
uh
that's that's fun to see those reactions
what am I drinking I am drinking
raspberry Crush by citizen cider
ah
see
Shirley Jackson wrote Amazing Stories
good pick
good pick for a short story Rider all
right there's some super chats I've gone
to Rusty Ralston
thank you so much uh for the Super Chat
happy birthday Vera be glad you aren't
in my shoes uh when you're angry at a
local production company that you're
supposed to be interning with completely
ghosting you uh oh no
no local theater drama
it's a thing I I have I have been there
whoo
uh gamer Jamie I love first of all I
love the way you spell that happy
birthday Vera thank you very much I
appreciate that greatly get any good
birthday presents I did I got I got a
fair few from some very very lovely
people some of whom are in the chat
Alan Moore Grant Morrison I haven't read
a lot of Grant Morrison so I'm actually
not in a position to make a call on that
just spilled red wine everywhere this is
my villain origin story
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know what I need to do I need to
find an excuse maybe on Tick Tock to
[Music]
um
uh
uh pull out my full-blown
maniacal villain laugh again I haven't
done that in a while
anyways oh I should check the Discord
oh told me twice
Carolyn catching me on that
sorry Carolyn and thank you for telling
me yet again
am I defense a lot of super chats have
been coming in that I've been trying to
keep up to but yes I am very sorry for
missing that
check in the Discord back in a minute
let's see what do we got
reminder the Council of Geeks Discord is
a patreon exclusive perk and there is a
channel there to be able to ask
questions specifically on the Stream
so let me see what I got I'll be working
but happy birthday I hope it's a good
one oh happy birthday happy birthday
uh we share our birthday ah a couple
more happy birthdays keeping these light
my friends and I've been obsessed with
flux lately I'm wondering if you ever
played it oh so the oh oh the game
because it I was wearing it it's got two
x's I don't know if you've ever played
it and if so do you like it because I've
heard it's very divisive among board
game snobs I've played it once
like
five years ago I did have fun but I
don't even remember how to play it now
it's been too long
I learned it and played it once I did
enjoy it
happy birthday do you have any
recommendations for the trans rights
readathon oh
I should
I don't
um I can tell you what I should read
Because I had a copy of it lent to me
was genderqueer I really need to read
that
um but I haven't yet so I don't know if
I can recommend it
I'll tell you I'll I'll tell you what I
will recommend it's a graphic uh novel
it is called The Prince and the
dressmaker I recommend that very highly
and despite what Scholastic in the US
will say it is all ages appropriate
there's a story behind that but I don't
have time
I've been enjoying your and Jesse's
takes on Babylon 5 for all its flaws it
has my favorite overall story arc of any
Space Opera along with some of my
favorite characters do you have any
comments on the overall story arc so far
it's progressing well as Jesse and I
have known him multiple times it the
show has a very
very good understanding of the
progression of fascism in specific with
what's going on with Earth in that and
and it's telling good stories even
outside of that I'm pretty I'm pretty
impressed with it so far I can see ways
in which it could go off the rails for
me but we'll see and it's still pretty
solid so far
all right we've got a few here
uh in your Gary lineker video you said
you're kind of Eat the Rich at this
point I get that sentiment but don't you
think there's a moral difference between
getting rich by like being a skilled
athlete and getting rich by like being a
business owner who exploits and
underpays their workers I mean if you
want to get Marxist about it I think pro
football players would technically be
counted as part of the proletariat since
they're employed by someone else and get
paid a salary I'll be at a very high one
yeah those comparisons don't work
because yes while it is true that your
um you know your famous sports stars or
your actors or whatever are certainly
far far far
richer than
um the vast majority of people
they don't come close
to business owners and CEOs they don't
even
they like you need to remember yeah a
sports player makes a lot of money
somebody's writing their check
the people like and I'm not gonna say
that like sports people and people of
that level of wealth don't irritate me
they can that's not where my rage is my
rage is at the level of the person who
is signing the paycheck of a
multi-millionaire Sports uh Superstar
that's who I feel needs to be taken down
badly
do you think it's possible to make a
progressive or anti-bigatory message in
a piece of media so explicit that
right-wing fans won't try to deny it's
there
um
well yes but then they'll just decry see
that's the thing there's plenty of media
like that but that's the one that
right-wing fans just go oh they went
woke oh it's proper it's sjw propaganda
if they can deny it they will if they
can't they'll denounce it
ah excuse me uh but there's more
contacts to this question
remember I said my hero Academia
subreddit got mad at me for suggesting
one of the bad guys is misogynist in his
origin story episode they literally show
him saying all women in his family are
useless referring to his mother as his
abusive dad's property and zoning out
her words every time she tries to give
him emotional advice but apparently it
was uh ridiculous of me to suggest that
misogyny is something to do with why he
turned out bad I mean
you can't make somebody grapple with
something they don't want to Grapple
with
people will put on the world's biggest
blinders if they are not prepared to
confront something or they want to
pretend it doesn't exist
remember you made that video about
uh tomboys uh way back when you ever
notice in media that focuses on tomboys
the other characters tend to care about
gender Norms in an unrealistically
old-fashioned way recently I've been
watching A Slice of Life anime about a
tomboyish girl and I've noticed the
other characters gender expectations are
kind of ridiculously old-fashioned like
they treat the protagonist as freakish
for preferring to wear jeans and
t-shirts on days off even though that's
relatively normal for girls today I
think that is probably part of the
reason why a lot of famous tomboy
stories you know things like
um
A League of Their Own or
God why am I suddenly drawing a blank
fried green tomatoes and a lot of those
characters are often period pieces you
kind of have to set them back at an
earlier point in time to when those
Norms were more rigidly enforced
but because tomboys are such fun
characters and some creators have not
been able to divorce the Tomboy
archetype from the Tomboy story which is
people being like Oh a girl doing things
that's very normal for a girl to do
nowadays but if you don't transplant
that into a period piece yeah it can be
pretty dissonant it's one of those
things where
you know when you Embrace a Trope you
need to be very careful about the
circumstances you put that Trope in
because sometimes with tropin and of
itself might be I mean most tropes are
fairly neutral but you put it in the
wrong circumstances or the wrong setting
or you give it to the wrong character
and suddenly it doesn't work or it
doesn't make sense so that's the kind of
thing that strikes me out of
carelessness for going I want to tell I
want to do that kind of story and then
not thinking about what settings that
story actually works in
no questions from me just a happy
birthday thank you no questions here
either happy birthday
uh three questions do you think the LGBT
community canceling their TV license in
the UK might actually do more harm than
good things as most TV license
cancellations are being attributed to
elderly people being fed up with rope
reporting and political correctness I
don't know enough about the ins and outs
of the specific funding and or the
narratives around the funding of the BBC
in terms of the licenses to have a say
on that I think that's a
valid concern
and I will say in general that for all
my criticisms of the BBC I don't want to
see it go away
I think the idea of a publicly funded
um broadcast station especially one that
does news is not an inherently bad thing
in fact it can be an amazing thing it
just isn't right now so I don't really
want to see it defunded and obliterated
it's one of those things where like this
thing's really messed up I don't want it
gone I want it fixed but it is it is a
difficult thing where like
how do you impact that
you know and starving it of money is a
way to impact it but the thing is people
will have to try and assume or make a
guess as to why you withheld your money
it's one of those things where like you
can take one of the recent Disney movies
The Strange World and there are people
who have argued oh nobody went to see it
because one of the lead characters is
gay that's possible but it's also
possible that they just didn't Market
the thing worth a damn
like the fact that when people are in
regards to a piece of media or an
organization like the BBC
people will do what they're gonna do you
know choose not to see it choose not to
fund it whatever and it then Falls onto
well pundits and people like me but also
the people signing checks to decide why
they made those choices why they went to
see it why they didn't go to see it and
they're largely going to latch on to one
or two things that might be the majority
or might just happen to fit a narrative
they already want to push but aren't
necessarily reflective of reality it's
part of why voting with your dollars is
a [__] concept
because your reason for spending or not
spending that dollar cannot be fully uh
communicated to the business or the
individual in question unless you are
personally talking to their face here's
why I'm giving you money here's why I'm
not giving you money
they're free to interpret why you did or
didn't spend money with them and they
don't have to come to the conclusion
that you want them to come to
uh if the midnight Suns ever got their
own movie who would be your dream lineup
of Heroes I don't know enough about that
lineup
I know it's like it's like it's Ghost
Rider it's blade it's Moon Knight
it's multiple versions of Ghost Rider
actually I think
um I forget who else is in it morbius
might be in it I don't know I don't know
the specific lineup very well I do like
in general this kind of group is of some
darker Heroes especially in something
like Marvel which is a generally lighter
toned world I like having those corners
of Darkness so like
given the mural movie in general I'm
here for it
other than Davies and moffatt who are
some of your favorite Doctor Who writers
and have you ever thought about listing
them in a top 10 or top five of too many
I'd have to like go through the whole
thing and I have thought about it I
haven't done it though obviously
obviously Toby Woodhouse did some really
good work
um so that's a name that Springs to mind
Mark Gadis is not very high he was a he
was a repeat but he often frustrated me
um there's another one that I am
drawing a blank on
but that those are some of those are the
two main other recurring ones besides
moffa Davies or chimnal uh who are
spraying to mind and one of them I liked
and one of them not quite so much
all right I'm almost done with the
Discord folks I promise I'll be back in
just a couple minutes
if you could go on a whirlwind tour of
the UK the UK where would you go and for
how long
um Scotland and I'd probably stay there
I do Scotland for a week because I think
I'd be much more liable to feel safe in
Scotland I would not feel safe in
England and I don't know if I'd feel
safer in Wales or Northern Ireland
Northern Ireland but I definitely would
not feel safe in England with things as
they are right now so Scotland I'll go
to Scotland
do you have a sequel for dreams of fire
planned sort of I have another book set
in the same world that I have most of a
first draft done on and I do hope to get
back to one of these days no promises on
when if you're asking about a direct
sequel at present no doesn't mean never
just means not right now and what would
you do if you had enough to had enough
to have your basic needs met I would buy
so many cosplays commissioned so much
custom art and fund
so many artistic projects of my friends
and creators I admire that's what I'd be
doing
uh do you have a favorite horror movie
franchisor series franchisor series not
really because I generally feel that
horror works better in a self-contained
setting so like my favorite horror movie
is the Invasion of the Body Snatchers
1978 version
um but series and franchise is like
horror I don't think holds up to being
scary multiple times with the same core
thing that doesn't mean that there can't
be fun with those like they can be fun
to be had in those kinds of franchises
but they're horror friend the kind of
things that end up as franchises aren't
really my thing
all right I'm back I'm back I'm back in
the main chat thank you for your
patience
how do I settle a dispute with a cow
depends on on what the uh the point of
conflict is I suppose all right
got some more stuff in super chats
purple Raider thank you so very much
Hades down is coming to London I'm so
excited and wanted to share happy
birthday oh I'm assuming you're gonna go
see it and I hope that you enjoy it
personally I wonder if a lot of girls
labeled tomboyish and the past were
neurodivergent
um that is possible John vinyls that is
certainly a possibility Supreme Omega
thoughts on DC turning Tim into another
sad orphan where his dad was killed his
girlfriend was torches to death as
superhero Pals also healed that was a
very stupid decision
that was that was taking a unique
situation A not only a robin but a
superhero in general with a supportive
home life and a stable social group and
just turning him into a freaking angry
loner just like every other freaking
person
in superheroes especially in Batman
related no that was stupid that was a
stupid terrible decision it was awful
and I hate that they did it
Jennifer
ditto de Benedito de Benedito
thank you for the Super Chat however it
is pronounced thank you very much I
appreciate that
um I am going to wrap it up soon I see
that some folks are calling it a night
already
speaking of Acts of villainy how much uh
would you suffer if we convince you to
watch the doctor in distress
covering a bunch of Doctor Who fan Maids
if you're trying to set up like a whole
um
like um
Clockwork Orange situation like where my
eyes are pried open
yeah no please don't
screams and Donald Sutherland nicely
done Carolyn thank you for that well
caught
that movie's so good it is so it is
I had movies masterful every time I've
gone back and rewatched wow every time
I've gone back and rewatched it it has
messed me up again I have never watched
Invasion of the Body Snatchers from 1978
and not
um had a really bad night's sleep and
messed up dreams every single damn time
been watching that movie since
I was like 13. still happens
um but I also noticed new stuff like new
small things that make it more
unsettling little things that put you on
edge it's masterfully made that movie
movie have you ever been to a Scholastic
Book Fair oh yeah when I was a kid
that's where I used to pick up uh
volumes of Calvin and Hobbes
uh let's see
I see bacosta's answer to the how do you
settle a dispute with with a cow
uh I'm not gonna read it out loud but
that is that did make me laugh
thoughts on League you have
Extraordinary Gentlemen Volume 2 is my
second favorite island more comic just
behind Miracle Man I
I enjoyed it but I have not read either
volume in a long time
so my memories are pretty hazy on that
at this point
I'm looking forward to your reaction to
use of weapons because it's kind of
about someone who had a villain Arc and
is upset people won't forgive him ooh
that's interesting
hmm
just saying the cover is already up on
YouTube and my birthday's coming soon
Ben you frighten me sometimes
all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna finish this off we're gonna
call it a night this has been
this has been lovely
it's been lovely there's been one of the
lighter ones and not as many heavy
topics this time a couple but we got
through them
um I came out fully as Trent as a trans
woman the other week oh
which is probably not the best thing to
do in the UK right now
mostly had loving support from my
friends I'm really relieved to hear that
you have that support
Rowan it
it's gonna make
all the difference especially with
everything else going on over there
so congratulations on coming out and I'm
very happy to hear that you have that
support am I still a Calvin and Hobbs
fan oh yeah
oh yeah I haven't
um
I haven't Revisited it in a while but
um yeah I'm still a fan
yes 255 A.D I did I didn't I didn't
um
I didn't speak out loud on it so for
folks who don't know 255 A.D uh I read
some of uh their questions in the
Discord and uh at the very end it was a
visual dad
joke
um but like it's it's hard to describe a
visual joke so I didn't but I did see it
and I it
it was a good bad joke
there we go
thank you everybody for joining me
I hope that everyone has a great rest of
the night
I've had
a lovely day
I've had a lovely birthday
um you know thanks to
my friends to my partners
I've had a lot of people contributing to
what has been a nice weekend and a
wonderful day and thank you all for
joining me and for the well wishes and I
hope you all have
a great rest of the night I will be on
stream tomorrow on Twitch playing more
of uh super lesbian animal RPG
um so that'll be at 10 30 Eastern
Daylight time uh on Twitch tomorrow
Saturday's video will actually be live
uh as I do a tier ranking of MCU
properties
and that's what's coming up there'll
probably be some other stuff up in the
break room I don't know what it'll be
yet because I have to edit it and it
depends which one I edit first
that should do it for now
take care everybody and uh
please remember that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council I am just running
the meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
mccavity